joining us now for reaction from New
York is monica crowley who is a senior
fellow at the London Center for Policy
Research and with me here in Washington
is attorney Alan or alright guys you
heard my take here everybody needs to be
accountable Alan take a shot I think
everybody is accountable I think your
concerns are about the individuals who
are participating in the actual
investigation which doesn't mean the
investigation itself has a problem and
there has not been an outcome yet so why
the big concern if you're not guilty of
a crime then why is there a problem with
going through the process well my
concern is that when you populate your
investigative team with individuals who
have been either loyalists to the
previous administration or who actively
were engaged in the Hilary email
investigation and actually helped edit
commis announcement of the non
indictment indictment that that kind of
that entanglement is the mere appearance
of a conflict of interest is not what
you want an investigation like this an
appearance of a conflict in a case this
serious is enough to shake the
credibility of the investigation and I'm
not saying that everyone on the team is
bad or they don't have perfect I'm not
saying that but if the shoe on the other
foot and Hillary Clinton were be
investigated by a bunch of Trump
loyalists who had written terrible
things about Hillary and couldn't stand
Hillary and were texting their boyfriend
about Hillary
you'd be on this show going crazy about
them and I would actually say you know
something you have a point there well
maybe Hillary Clinton was the scape gods
for some Trump supporters but right now
this is just a bunch of stories about
individuals there's not a lot of
paperwork to back it up and this is what
the Justice Department does so the fact
that they also handle the Clinton emails
doesn't mean that they can't also handle
this this is what their duty is as
attorneys to sort of deal with the facts
before them so the facts that they
worked on prior cases or prior
administrations have nothing to do with
the instant case they're looking for the
facts and that's what we're going at so
you think it's okay for partisans to be
working on an investigation when they
were loyalists to the previous
administration and worked on the
exoneration of Hillary Clinton you don't
have anything in the shoe on the other
foot you would have any probably have
you because they're professionals
the only one perfect you ever walked the
face of the earth one perfect Jesus
Christ okay none of us are perfect none
of us are flawless and a conflict of
interest and a parent conflict or an
appearance of a conflict in a case like
this is not what you want to do Bob
Miller is a smartest person around like
he's the smartest guy who ever lived
apparently but he had no problem
bringing in these people who hate Donald
Trump they despise the man I don't know
how you can be independent in your
thought and process if you hate him as
much as they did Monica to get you got
to get you in on this
look you know Alan says they're
professionals are doing their job and
I'm sure there are professionals in the
investigation and the Democrats say this
is much to do about nothing this is an
investigation that needs to reach its
conclusion and everybody's thrown a
bunch of you know pixie dust up in the
air hoping it goes away well it may be
in fact be true Laura that this entire
investigation was predicated on a lie
about Russian collusion which was
essentially a frame of Donald Trump the
these people never expected him to win
they expected Hillary Clinton to win and
so all of their possibly criminal and
unethical shenanigans throughout to the
campaign to torpedo Donald Trump and
then once he was elected during the
period of the transition to try to set
him up on a Russian collusion narrative
they felt that all of that evidence
would go away
and guess what Donald Trump is now the
president that evidence is being
uncovered left and right and that's why
the Democrats and the Muller team those
who have in fact been corrupted
according to the evidence as we know it
so far that's why they are so
frantically trying to deflect and lie
about not just what they did but about
the president as well I want you guys to
both listen to something that Adam
Schiff also of course on the Intel
committee what he said about this
concern about the investigators let's
watch why would you go to not have
accessori things the point was they
didn't care what was in the underlying
documents they wanted to make a
political statement they wanted to feed
the beast on Fox News they wanted to do
what they could to derail the Muller
investigation
Monica they're talking about the house
Intel committee wanting those four pages
that synopsis released to the public
they just want
feed the beast they want to feed Fox
well they're trying to discredit
Chairman Nunez they're trying to
discredit the House Intelligence
Committee that's under that's that's
exposing a lot of this corruption and a
lot of this evidence I can tell you
tonight Laura based on one of my one of
my sources that we will see all of these
documents we will see some nut and there
why do we need to wait to see you
process and we will see them I think the
process should be bipartisan because the
concern is bipartisan so why is only
part of the committee already seen the
memo in the rest of the committee has it
furthermore why has DOJ not vetted the
memo with regards to national security
which is the primary issue of all of
this in the first place so it doesn't
sound like a very sound you know the
attacks on the attacks on chairman
noonas and and a House Intelligence
Committee that's doing incredible work
here
look when they talk about well those who
are attacking that their investigation
are trying to discredit the FBI in the
DOJ and attacking these institutions as
dangerous no you know what the top
hierarchy of the FBI and DOJ Laura
discredited themselves and the world
process from all of this Laura is Barack
Obama the idea that all of these people
freelanced all of this or that anything
happens I think look the Democrats have
a chance to see this memo they could all
go to the secure room to read this memo
only I think a few have I'm always for
like more sunshine more transparency
let's see what it is let's see if it
mean maybe the Republicans are over
blowing it maybe this is not a big deal
I don't know I like to see it for myself
although it seems people seem really hot
and bothered by it so I think we should
all we will see it and guys thank you
very much I love to have you both back